[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Heena zoom los Allah Ta'ala gardant un
costume respectueux marche
dit-il gagner un corps  J'utilise ou autorise
un corps de lézard su
hajime aurait peur que la partie mangia ne
sache pas que la lance poursuivie les hommes
devraient être maintenant est une ferme d'épées en papier devrait
être maintenant sa lance
qui est blessée jusqu'à présent whiticus utilise le
polissage ganging qui ne le regarde pas  plus
heureux devoir label montre hood nama people
kuzey don't love your loss sir Phoenix
we may in a complex ever you et la
música pop a party love you lost mec
fan shiqi aujourd'hui
[Musique]
[  Musique]
en supposant qu'aucun salafiste Allah Davina n'est loin
de la guerre des costumes, a-t-il dit, gagnez une fête Je
fais généralement un beau costume une fête à l'épée
ou la ferme ne devrait
pas être c'est grand, nous l'avons vu jusqu'à présent
, passons à votre costume de gangee soufflant Oh
doggone tre  atment un dhuni célèbre
yoson un kuzey palpable ne riez pas vous
savez monsieur les porcs nous pouvons dans une pompe lèche
leur foire vous perdez
[Musique]
Je suis un mon nom rit vous avez perdu bon fan
shiqi aujourd'hui
[Musique]
rit de ton nez fatigue de midi obtenir le jour
vous